he leaned a Rio as an excellent citizen
to start a conversation in this country
that terrorism and war is a connected
phenomena both are connected actually
there is a class fellow of mine Robert
Pape at the University of Chicago he has
been funded by Pentagon he has complete
database of all cases of suicide bombing
and he says when drone attacks go up
suicide bombing goes up when American
troops go up in any country suicide
bombing go goes up so what he sees is
the terrorism and war or a connected
phenomena there was no suicide bombing
in Pakistan Afghanistan Iraq anywhere
when did it start when bombing started
so you see we can condemn terrorism all
day long make it is six pillar of Islam
or 78 or ninth and the tenth unless our
neighbor realize what is the
contribution of war and drones and
torture in creating terrorists after
terrorists after terrorists this thing
not going to go away today it will be
named Isis tomorrow it will be some
other name and day before yesterday it
was al Qaeda so we need to we have a
responsibility to be a good Muslim and a
good Muslim mean that we are a good
neighbor so we can have connection and
communication with our neighbors at the
same time we are able to be a good
citizen pointing out that how our
country is hurting